hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's VR there was a spider in my
headset I'm not lying about that there's
a whole last spider big ol spider in my
headset I cleared it out I think I took
a vacuum to the headset and I think I
got it out of there but it may have laid
eggs so this horror game is about to get
a whole lot more interesting
I don't think spiders are a part of five
nights at freddy's but i'm fully
prepared for that to be the event
reality of what I'm dealing with
okay hey Freddy how you doing I'm gonna
pretend like everything is good because
it probably is see that's the thing it
probably is fine it's probably 100
percent okay
there are probably no spiders in this
headset but as you may be able to relate
to if you find a spider in your headset
and then you have to put that headset on
to record a video you don't just get too
comfortable with that being said let's
get into the new five nights at Freddy's
VR content cuz it came out Halloween
might be over but it's still time for
the spooks oh yes what do we have here
pirate ride corn maze Oh
oh my god there's so many new things
wait a minute that's a lot more new
things than I thought there was gonna be
oh there there still hasn't been a thing
Oh
Oh No I beat plush can patch I didn't
beat hallway but I'm gonna pretend like
I did and I think I did night one of
whatever this is and I don't know if
there's anything over here no no no okay
so there's nothing in the other world
about what's going on here okay so what
I'm gonna do first is I'm gonna do the
pirate ride because that's new and then
everyone's gonna pretend like I did
hallway and I don't have to do that one
again because I'm dealing with spiders
in my eyes okay I've got spiders in my
eyes okay anyway shoot targets with
blaster pull trigger press trigger to
continuum get high score hey that sounds
fun that doesn't sound deadly at all and
I definitely am gotta keep forgetting
about the possibility there might be
like what if it laid eggs what if it
laid eggs and there's about a million
baby spiders that are about to come
crawling all over my eyeballs because
I'm not about that but I am about
getting the high score oh oh I love
these rides I love these hey this is
cool
I love these rides both goddamnit
hi
I love these rides ah I could have had
them all okay oh hey well find me
oh okay so spamming is not punishment so
this is good hey I did it
I think hey hey I could have gotten it
all in the first one if I hadn't known
that spamming was an option but I didn't
so you know it is what it is ah what did
I hit I have my microphone oh I did it
yep
[Music]
easy okay so I did it
Oh what I didn't know that that was
coming
what are you doing what are you even
thinking about doing oh that's not good
okay whoo hi hey are you doing hey this
is fine this is fine that's fine
oh hey what in the world mer chica what
what oh my but those but how am I
supposed to be able to get the high
score if you're not gonna walk
[Laughter]
are you serious
the real treasure was friendship all
along hey pretty good wait what wait
that's it Oh what I could've done better
I know what could have done better I
know the prize of friendship all along
but I coulda done better
hi oh my hand sorry you're a little bit
dastardly to hold there listen when you
went down in that sea did you see
anything unsavory I'm strange about know
what dear man I didn't meet you
stop going seeking adventure and other
people's gullets ain't some big monster
to go plundering it keep in mind that
this DLC pack is nothing more than a
festive holiday themed add-on which has
absolutely no hidden intent or purpose
sounds good to me I bet there's
something to get a high score in that
game but I'm gonna do the left d-pad
right d-pad high but pressing don't trip
Oh God find the key in it you're pulling
it you're pulling the page right out of
the own Slendy Slough ain't you oh you
are is you
oh you is well I know you is but I ain't
about to turns out secretly that I hate
it oh I hate it oh I hate it okay
oh yeah got a turn yeah I hate it oh I
hate it so much
why would that even be a thing that you
would consider why would you even try
wait a minute hey whose stip steppin
over there I don't I feel I should run I
could get spiders in my eyes at any
would my god which I'm gonna run oh I
can't run it's very slow on the run
thank you right wait no no no no I can't
back up I can't I can't go any farther
backwards oh I'm stuck
you are not fast you were quite slow Oh
God
this is the slowest death of my life
okay this is the slowest this is awful
in terms of slowness I'm going for it
baby I'm going for it here I go full
speed you'll never get me
whoo turning apparently you'll never get
me oh oh oh that's right oh hello I hid
I think I hit anyway
I did it I beat him I beat him in his
own game
this fool thought he could beat me
turns out you could not okay alright
well easy enough I just got to find
myself a key I'm sorry about that
oh god you're not coming this way
oh please oh god wait what well I'm this
way
okay we're fine oh I have the key
question mark oh so I just gotta get I
gotta I gotta get back
oh oh come back
why would he come back okay Oh
God why'd ya bout that the job to go
what are you doing what do you what are
you doing okay whatever he's kind of
crazy no okay I'm just gonna go I'm
going for it
whoo I shouldn't have gone for it I'm
going for I shouldn't go for it
oh oh oh wow dad was too fast okay that
should never happen that was awful
why was that a thing okay I remember how
to get back which I don't I think oh oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God
God okay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God
okay easy peasy it is the easiest pc's
thing I've ever Brees Eid easiest brizia
sting Oh God
hi hey everybody how you doing
main palmar ki-moon here back at it
again with another spicy adventure there
might be ants spiders in my eyes but I'm
having a good time
hey bud see ya if you don't hear my
breathing are there are spiders in my
eyes
I don't know okay
okay which way am I headed where are you
coming back he must just know where I am
at all times he just knows he knows
where I am at all times at all times
through this guy screw this guy screw
this guy I've got to be close
oh I'm not close oh god I'm not close oh
god oh no
there's no hidey hole oh god no not like
this not like this now like this Oh God
give me a hidey hole hole God please I
need ideal there's another key fob God
oh jeez oh okay I can't see I'm blind
I don't know I'm lying down line Oh keys
away okay good so the terrible news
oh [ __ ] hi oh hi whoa okay the terrible
news is that there is another key which
might mean that there's more than
another key which might mean there's
like a lot of keys or something like
that
none of kisses you have dude the thing
how many keys is you have is my question
how many keys is oh that's not a good
sign good sound okay and
okay moving on
you coming in for me yeah yeah you see
me okay so that's a way to get rid of
him didn't expect you to do that good to
know that that's a thing that can happen
okay there's a green part
oh no no no hide Red Bear good to see
you good to see you hey we got a fence
between us or else you'd be a problem
all right try that again I think that I
know the strategy behind it at least now
I got spiders in my eyes okay let's just
there's landmarks with any good with any
good maze is landmarks so I know where
that is so in relation I'm gonna start
south I'm gonna call that south that's
weird you call that south I'm gonna use
that as my landmark to make my way
downtown why don't you John good for you
good for you good for you you're great
you're also good okay oh that sounds bad
okay so there's a water tower okay
just got a if I get my landmarks it's
like these Lundy's man it's like it's
like Slendy z-- you know what I mean
just likes Lindy's [ __ ] there he is
hey bud good thing you can't get me at
the first one apparently too slow
oh hey that's gonna make us faster
there's probably four there's probably
definitely for what are you gonna do
buddy huh are you gonna do oh you go get
me Oh what you cannot cuz I am
oh okay so I just got to go find the
other to get back home and I'm good
right oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
gotta go oh [ __ ]
hang on gotta get my bearings where am I
where's it okay okay hey buddy
were you at pal we're yeah okay there he
is okay okay so he liked these spawns
when that happens for some reason I
don't know why not okay
cuz all I know is that I got a better
chance if he goes away and I have a nice
or you could absolutely not do any of
what you're doing I don't know what
you're doing but I don't like it like he
knows where I am
oh okay I don't worry but he's near now
he's far come on take your head yeah
okay okay
all right okay did you this one okay
good okay I don't like that at all but
it is what it is okay just one more I
think
just one more one sweet savory delicious
more is it in there where it was before
no way no way no way no way no how
okay come here come here are you doing
yeah you gonna yeah what's you doing
what are you doing you know oh okay good
okay I feel good I feel confident I feel
oh oh please tell me there's a okay
there's no you okay I'm just gonna go
for it I guess
okay don't for it okay oh god please no
please
okay just guys see this
he's gonna come get me I'm gonna hold
God huh okay that's good now I just keep
going I go back to the beginning
where's it oh [ __ ] no no not like this
no oh God thank you thank you thank you
spot me do it do it god damn it
okay I'm just gonna go in it then that's
normal that's normal behavior okay you
just see me dirt something I don't know
see me okay
continue on I think I'm getting close to
the center I don't know where my
landmarks are but there's another one so
that's good
there's the water tower so it's got to
be over this way there's that guy I
remember this one okay where's the it
okay where's yet okay he's over there
somewhere which way is he coming from
coming this way yeah and I'm Scott free
I'm Scott free I'm Scott free I'm Scott
for you I'm Scott Cawthon free I'm Scott
frickin free free free free here's the
key okay what are you doing what is this
not working shouldn't this be working
isn't this worried ooh what was that I
thought I saw something move
shouldn't that be going to the thing
there oh [ __ ] oh god where is he
okay okay easy I would have thought that
this would be the thing that I needed is
this not the thing that I need is there
one more key or something it really
looks like all of them okay please okay
fine that's not working okay so the only
guest that I have is it maybe there's
one more mmm okay but this is easy
enough to deal with I'm gonna try that
side over there because I haven't tried
really in that closet
okay I'm gonna go to the other side here
and I'm gonna take a left
I haven't been over in this area very
much so it's gotta be over here
somewhere if there is another one which
there might not be okay spot me get in
there oh my god oh my god you almost
screwed me oh my god
well that's different I haven't seen
that so that's gotta be something good
come around the corner there it's fine
Hey Oh God why hello there it goes easy
be easy P easy one and easy me why Spa
me like that okay I don't know if
there's another one so I'm kind just
wandering around hoping there's another
one and that this isn't just a fruitless
adventure tell nothingness oh yeah I
think there was I think it's gotta be
just for right no [ __ ] where you at when
you want a big boy yeah yeah okay maybe
the gates I don't know there's like a
yellow gate maybe that maybe I got going
gate I don't know I don't know noon is
there was no instructions owed I had to
go there and the other way well I'm
still oh oh my god what did they just
bought in there did it really just do
that to me did it think that it could
get away with doing that to me hey bud
hey come up that way that's interesting
very interesting hey bud um by the way
I'm in here oh I thought I wasn't close
enough for a second there okay here's a
key wait I could have found any key and
I could have gone
[Music]
are you I couldn't I risked spiders in
my iceberg it's fine
give me my prize hey you're not
something I can talk to take my wage
okay all right okay all right well you
know what actually I'm just gonna take a
little breather from that because I've
already tempted the hand of fate to not
put spiders in my eyes so I'm just gonna
leave fate to it that's I'm good okay I
don't think I have spiders in my eyes so
I'm probably fine okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll play
more of this there's a bunch more game
modes in there that I got to get through
and that hallway one that I don't like
and I'm pretty sure there's gonna be
more that I don't like but hey at least
I overdid that one I'm an overachiever
you know how I do if you have not
checked out a heist with markiplier my
god what are you doing with your life
that's so good there's 31 endings you
gotta check it out link right in there
in the description thank you all so much
and happy illness honest all of you
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]